let me let me show you an example that I
that I talked about um earlier today
this is from wishtv.com I believe it's a
Indianapolis Channel 8. it is fat
shaming to point out that people who get
coveted and are uh who are being
hospitalized tends to be obese so we
have this tweet from I don't know who
this person is but Melissa cancels
student debt burn is fat shaming the new
CDC government policy the the last week
of CDC gov tweets has been awful what
did the CDC say they say a new CDC mmwr
finds that two out of three children in
adolescents hospitalized for covid had
one or more underlying health conditions
most commonly obesity fewer than one
percent of uh fewer than one percent
eligible for covid-19 vaccination have
been vaccinated learn more they didn't
insult people for being fat they didn't
say it was bad to be fat they didn't say
you're ugly or you're nasty they simply
said here's a fact and that was mocked
so what we see here is I suppose virtual
virtue signaling perpetuating a cycle of
Decay and destruction in this country so
the reality is if you want to live a
longer life if you want to have a lower
chance of going to the hospital with
covid lose weight
eat better exercise talk to a medical
professional and a health and nutrition
specialist who can help you live better
but instead of hearing things like why
not take some vitamin D and get some
sunlight and breathe some fresh air get
some exercise we hear everything has to
align perfectly with whatever tribe
people find themselves in
this woman it's fat shaming to point out
a fact
well that's that's the tribe they're in
but it's also look how lovely and slim
she is like the person doing this like
these people like like you know there's
such a hypocrisy there you know the same
thing with like you see this a lot with
marriage right like you see this sort of
liberal culture that's you know often
telling people oh marriage is an
Antiquated institution like people don't
have to get married stop shaming people
you know we have to promote all kinds of
family structures and the people saying
that are all you know affluent Highly
Educated people who are married who are
you know benefiting very much from
Marriage from an economic point of view
because marriage has been very much
correlated with higher earnings and so
you have this kind of like this this
this tiny tiny Elite that is impervious
to the costs of its BS right to the cost
of saying oh no it's totally fine to be
obese like that'll never hurt you you
know like we have to respect people's
choices to be this way right or it's not
a choice right like while at the same
time they would never in a million years
allow their own children to live in that
way I find it really really it's it's
terrible obesity is definitely a choice
in 2003 I started to get obese so I
stopped eating McDonald's and drinking
Coke every day for lunch
some people have a genetic
predisposition some people don't maybe
but I don't know fasting is like a lost
art
it's true but there's still the reality
of you can't gain weight if you don't
ingest the calories
so it may be more difficult for some
people but people could choose I don't
know I just look at cheesecake and I'm
like getting the weight but they've got
they've got hold on there hold on I've
been doing keto cheesecake is very fatty
so it's excellent so long it's sweetened
with allulose yes or erythritol I don't
like erythritol though the sugar alcohol
stuff but we've got we've got keto
cheesecake and it tastes exactly the
same in fact you know we got some in the
green room so uh you can try definitely
so it looks really good I got some
regular cheesecake I'm gonna be
partaking in that myself
the bigger issues that's your issue of
like that you know like people like
living a lifestyle that benefits them
and their children and then hoarding the
benefits for themselves with this
rhetoric that sounds like social justice
but actually is sentencing the poor to
live much worse lives that they would
never let their own children live
exactly that's the point and they're
just trying to do it for profit like
when you see these ads like it's okay to
be larger oh that would be so much much
easier that's the thing is like yuvall
Levin has this great quote he's like
he's like Washington would be so much
easier to navigate if everyone who
showed up was like
I'm gonna get all the money and all the
power when actually what happens is
everyone shows up and says I am going to
heal the world I'm gonna fix everything
I'm gonna make everything better like
they truly this woman truly believes
that fat shaming is worse than dying of
coven you know that's the things like
they really believe it and I know this
because I was once one of them well take
take a look at this uh this image this
famous image from Cosmo this is healthy
11 women on why Wellness doesn't have to
be one size fits all no it's not obesity
is not healthy but she's not obese she
looks great I think technically that is
obesity no that's that's near morbid
obesity yeah see Americans have become
so desensitized
eat a steak eat eat and like dude stop
eating for 18 hours this woman she looks
great she's probably morbidly obese
really yeah people Americans are so
desensitized to what overweight really
is you'd be you'd be surprised like
people who we would describe as chubby
in America are obese this woman is
probably morbidly obese or at least on
the border of not the fattest you've
ever seen and then this woman here
clearly I I would assume is is morbid
obesity and she also looks great to me I
mean as a human I mean by all means she
looks really healthy like it's clear
that she has a lot of muscle yeah well I
think it's true it's possible it's 100
true that one size is not fit all when
it comes to health but I do have to say
that this was actually probably my
biggest red pill when I was 11 years old
I looked at what feminism had to say
about the fat acceptance movement and I
was like are you effing joking that is
not going to help women live longer
happier lives if they really wanted
women to live and see their grandkids
they would be promoting being active
finding something that you like to do
like yoga doing something healthy with
yourself there's there's so many
negative Health consequences of being
overweight higher blood pressure
um heart disease heart disease
especially
I just want to be I just want to be I
don't I don't see any muscles I'll just
be honest that's just my perspective but
a lot of this is being done in the guise
of helping them like we need to help
them we need to stop fat shaming them we
need to stop making them feel bad but
essentially what they're doing is
hurting these people even more later
down the line because they're not being
real with them they they they fake
caring about them because if they really
did truly care about someone who is
overweight they'd be like okay you know
let's do this let's hit the gym let's
work out let's let's change your diet
let's get away from the GMO like who do
you think they have a line into their
brains like nobody's buying this like
nobody who do you think they're
convincing they're not convincing
anybody their virtue signal is these
people they want to be known they feel
good it's not actually there's no person
who's like should I go on a diet no I
don't have to because well I would I
would disagree I would actually disagree
yeah because these are people of
influence we see we've seen this in a
lot of the corporate press saying fat
fat shaming is is bad it's okay to
accept your weight it's there's even you
know people giving out um you know
little notes to individuals to their
doctors saying hey don't ask me about my
weight which is absolutely ridiculous
your doctor should know how much you
weigh they should know how much your
weight has changed my favorite one of my
favorite memes is is all the pretty
obese Health bureaucrats
that were deciding on people's health
and and Joe Rogan made a very kind of
interesting point about this because he
said you know himself I've been working
on my health almost my entire life I've
been hitting the gym I've been I've been
watching what I eat I've been making
sure I take the right supplements I I
make sure I rest and there's someone who
does the complete opposite of that to
telling me what I should be doing for my
health you know that that should be
something we should consider we
shouldn't make it the end-all be-all but
at the end of the day you know tough
love and just being real and honest with
people goes a lot further than just kind
of patronizing them and pretending to
care about them which I think is going
to lead to more harm you know but also
you could go too far with it like every
time I go to La I'm like this is a
Godless place like yeah absolutely pure
materiality it's pure body worship and
it's like there's no Spirit at all it's
all it's kind of great and if you look
at the Fashion industry they are
normalizing you know women to look like
prepubescent boys yeah and I think a lot
of that has to do with the Jeffrey
Epstein connections but that's a whole
nother thing to even get into but
there's a lot of you know Jean-Luc
Bernay Les Wexner there's a whole lot of
individuals Victoria's Secret that are
involved in in portraying this image of
perfection of of these like girls who
are way too young who look like little
boys that that's that's something that
needs to be addressed and I I do agree
with you that's also another issue that
should be talked about should be
addressed just as the same as this one
because it's it's in the same realm of
providing an image that is absolutely
unfair and excuse people's minds to what
the reality of our of our real life is
and so do Instagram filters they have a
huge negative consequence for people's
mental health because they get this
image portrayed that everyone's perfect
they don't have any wrinkles they have
the perfect uh bosoms and the perfect uh
glass shape of wine of whatever they
want to describe themselves hourglass
who knows now
[Music]
look what we were just looking at just a
few moments to go here tell me I'm not
wrong that two white wine glasses upside
down yeah there you go that makes sense
thank you Ian so maybe a red wine glass
the main issue I was trying to get to is
we have a definitive fact that I think
the CDC said 30 percent of people who
hospitalized for covet are obese yes we
then have these virtue signaling media
types saying you're fat shaming by
telling people that yeah it's going to
get people killed yeah
if I could speak to this just because I
have struggled with my weight throughout
my life as people can probably tell I'm
struggling with it again I'm getting a
little chubby as chat likes to point out
oh my God so here's the deal I am the
standards here are way too long I just
know how I used to look and how I looked
before that so I'm like trying to get up
get back on target with my health and
it's it's interesting to me and
horrifying to watch compassion taking
the place of factual observation because
I understand wanting everyone to feel
like they look beautiful I completely
understand as a woman 100 very I I feel
deeply that everyone should understand
that they are Unique Individuals and
have like this unique perspective in
life but when it comes to helping people
live their best lives their longest
lives and get the most out of life I
think it's essential to point out that
things that are dangerous and I'm very
sorry that Health has become so
emotionally oriented because it's very
very important for people to live their
fullest lives and to be their best
selves to have an understanding that it
feels good to work out that it feels
great to see yourself get more flexible
and stronger that is really key to
living a better and stronger life and
with the covet thing I think this should
be a turning point in the American
understanding of our own weight as such
a key component of what happens to us in
the hospital we've disconnected from
that we think that what we eat has
nothing to do with how we live and how
we experience life but yeah when we
start looking at the larger impacts from
the sugar industry and the factory food
industry there's a lot to unpack there
with what is happening to our health
right now that definitely deserves a
real discussion and I think they're
preventing it from happening yeah they
for sure when Michelle Obama got into
office I should say when Barack got in
she started the let's move Campaign
which is basically let's move and cut
sugar out of our diets everyone yeah and
then a couple weeks went by radio
silence all of a sudden the sugar
industry is part of the White House
group and it changes into an exercise
campaign let's get up and move but what
they're telling people is you can eat
crappy food and then burn off the
calories and you'll be back to zero
that's not how it works you don't if you
if you you can't drink diet coke and
then work out and expect to be healthy
you can't put that stuff in your body
that you don't put poison in your body
in this industry like the tobacco
industry has commercials on TV peddling
it to kids this addictive substance
sucrose like there's some value to it
for sure but it's a drug we gotta treat
it like a drug so Eric Adams who's New
York's new mayor who's pretty great um
he has this he's a vegan and he became a
vegan because he got diabetes and he
started to lose his vision and
apparently as soon as he became a vegan
three weeks later it all came back and
all the symptoms started reversing
themselves and he pushes veganism as a
kind of racial Justice thing because he
says look at the foods that our
community is consuming these are like
foods that we had to learn how to make
because of slavery and because we were
only given scraps but now it's keeping
us enslaved and it's harming our bodies
and we have to have this he has like a
whole metaphor for it um and it's it's
very cool but I tend to think of the
Obesity epidemic very much along the
lines of like the deaths of despair like
from alcoholism and opioid addiction and
overdose and and suicide like it's it's
like it's happening among the lower
classes it's happening among the poor
and to me it signals like a kind of
hopelessness of giving up a sign of like
a spiritual dearth and a lack of
connection to to the nation like an
inability to see yourself as an active
participant in building up the nation
because it comes back to economics you
know the offshoring of these great jobs
like downward mobility of the working
class where you no longer see your life
as being on an upward trajectory thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time